we're joined now by debbie shriver one
of the country's leading authorities on
cults and the president of the
international cultic studies association
the schreiber thank you so much for
being here we've just seen a report with
some disturbing evidence of an alleged
cult at sarah lawrence here in new york
the evolution of cults from jonestown
and the religious zealots to a
university that's a new thing
college students in particular are
really good targets for
abusive groups
for any kind of
group that exercises coercive control
and
that's really because they are people in
transition
college students often are breaking away
from home the first time they're trying
to figure out what they want to do with
their lives
and they are
in a place often where they are making
friends new friends they don't have a
familiar group around them
and so they're easy targets for
groups that
don't have their goodwill at heart
and so are you seeing cults in other
college campuses around the country
yes we are yes we are um and we have
been really all along but more and more
now and the internet is making that even
more of an issue um there are a lot of
contacts are made through social media
often freshmen are targeted
there's a there's a group in particular
that
walks on campuses and asks students if
they know god the mother and that
encourages that student to stop and kind
of think i haven't heard that before and
the first thing you don't want to do is
engage in discussion with someone who's
who's trying to pull you in
as you study these groups how often do
you see a kind of sexual abuse aspect
involving the leaders
it's very common
that's certainly a way to control
people and it's very common very common
and the people under their control they
believe they're following their leader
is that really what it comes down to
they believe um that what they're doing
is for the greater good whatever that
might be
followers are
are
indoctrinated in a kind of thinking
and it happens over time and it happens
with peer pressure and separation from
everything that they're familiar with
and
you know we don't no one says i'm going
to join a cult
no one says that
but they can become enrapt in that
and controlled and do anything it is
that the leader tells them to do if they
believe it's in the greater good
were you surprised at the evidence
that's been presented in court in the
trial here in new york involving larry
ray and sarah lawrence students
i find it
you know i think i'm always surprised in
a sense
i'm always shocked
i'm always stunned
no matter what it is
and how i've heard it before and i think
sometimes one aspect of this
is that college students are smart
and
we have an idea that people join cults
who are not smart or maybe they're on
drugs or maybe they're out on the street
and homeless but the truth is
cult leaders want people who are smart
smart people will raise money for them
smart people will draw in more people
and recruit for them
and
so
in many respects
it
it's not surprising to see how this
could happen
in a college environment but it's still
stunning
what do you tell parents of students who
fall under the sway of these groups how
to recognize it and how to break the
hold
that's a really good question because
parents often do come to us and say i'm
worried about my son or daughter because
um they seem to be
meeting with this group that i don't
know much about don't understand and
their behaviors are changing
and
what we'd like to to do is talk about
what behaviors are you seeing
what kinds of things um concern you
and then the bottom line is to continue
communicating with your child no matter
what
arguing
about what they're
told
um and their belief system is not a way
to
uh
keep that commun communication tie open
so the important thing is to maintain
communication to be there no matter what
sometimes ask questions
about what do they believe and say
that's interesting
i haven't heard that before and let me
tell you
something that
may be in contrast to that but something
that i've thought about and so to engage
in discourse whenever you can is a
really good thing to do and also i would
say always be there because
it's
unlikely that that
child will not come back they'll they'll
likely come back to to their parents at
some point now maybe for money or it may
be for an interest of the group but um
they usually come back
all right debbie schreiber of the
international occultic studies
association thank you so much for being
with us here tonight
thanks for having me appreciate it
up next this week's winners and losers
in the media including the fox news
correspondent who was doing everything
just right you're watching brian ross
investigates on the long crime trial
network
time now for this week's winners and
losers in the media as chosen by the
editors of mediaite and we're joined by
aidan mclaughlin who's the
editor-in-chief of mediaite which like
the law and crime trial network is part
of the dan abrams media group and aiden
you've chosen as your winner this week
jennifer griffin the fox news
correspondent for her role in helping
her injured colleague benjamin hall be
evacuated from ukraine
there was news gathering on the
outskirts of kiev was hit tragically by
russian fire
killing two of our colleagues pierre
zakszewski and sasha
kushinova correspondent benjamin hall
did survive the attack and is currently
receiving treatment at the landscape
medical center in germany but his
journey there
would have never happened if not for the
polish and ukrainian military defense
secretary lloyd austin in the department
of defense and the group save our allies
and also aiden because of the work of
jennifer griffin that's right so
jennifer griffin is fox news's senior
pentagon correspondent and in a new
interview with people magazine she
detailed how she helped benjamin hall
get out of ukraine into safety uh now we
both know that benjamin hall uh got
struck by artillery by russian artillery
uh last month while nougat news
gathering outside of kyiv in ukraine um
there was this desperate scramble to try
and get him out of ukraine to get him
medical attention because he was
seriously wounded
in that fire and
what happened was jennifer griffin found
out that he had been wounded
turned she was at one of the the
stand-ups outside of the white house
turned to john kirby who is the pentagon
spokesperson and asked if he could help
them get benjamin hall out of ukraine
now john kirby said to her that the
united states really couldn't do
anything militarily because they're not
allowed to put troops into ukraine right
now what he did say and this was
proposed by jennifer griffin the
pentagon correspondent is if if she
could somehow get benjamin hall to the
polish border get him across into poland
they could evacuate him from poland to
landstuhl uh which is a large military
hospital in germany and so jennifer
griffin worked with the pentagon with a
a
a company that's been rescuing uh
americans and allies out of ukraine um
and with the ukrainian military to pull
off this incredible evacuation of
benjamin hall from ukraine he was then
transported to germany and eventually to
the united states where he's being
treated and jennifer griffin has been
one of the fox news correspondents who
really has told the truth and what's
going on that's right she is one of the
more impressive uh correspondents at fox
news also the one uh that often um sort
of checks the rest of fox news
particularly the opinion hosts on uh
conspiracy theories um and she really
demonstrated how much uh she has
sourcing and knowledge of foreign
affairs and at the pentagon by being
able to pull off something so ambitious
such as getting a reporter out of a war
zone back to the united states safely
and very quickly how is ben hall doing
uh we don't know much fox news has not
given uh much of an update on what his
condition is last time we heard
ukrainian officials said that uh he had
wounded his leg that's about all we know
so far on the record all right and for
this week's losers you've chosen uh
conservative columnist and op-ed pundit
uh molly hemingway why
molly hemingway why is that that's right
ryan so in the past uh week or two we've
heard a lot about uh grooming and a lot
of accusations of pedophiles
that's because it's become
almost
conventional on the right to accuse
democrats of being pro-pedophilia and
one of the reasons for that is
judge jackson joe biden's current uh
supreme court pick um has been accused
of republican lawmakers of uh being
lenient on people that have been accused
of uh child pornography and child
pornography cases that she oversaw
molly hemingway this conservative pundit
for the federalist has now taken to
accusing mitt romney who said he's going
to support judge jackson's uh
confirmation
of being somehow sympathetic to
pedophiles because he's supporting this
justice who i think most people would
agree is eminently qualified for the job
um it has gone as far as marjorie taylor
greene the congresswoman woman who has
also leveled allegations of uh pedophile
sympathizers um against her opponents it
used to be something that was relegated
to the fringes of the conservative
movement to cue anon this idea that your
opponents are pedophiles now it's
something that's being espoused by a
congresswoman
and a prominent conservative pundit who
appears frequently on fox news and seems
to be straight out of the q anon
playbook that's right uh you'll recall
that the the q on uh believers uh think
that uh the world is run by a cabal of
satanic worshiping worshiping pedophiles
um but again that used to be something
that was dismissed by uh conservative
thought leaders unfortunately for some
reason now it's being embraced by them
i truly hope that it's something that
gets stamped out
of the conservative movement we'll see
if that happens all right thank you
aidan mclaughlin fascinating molly
hemingway the loser this week and thanks
to all you for joining us tonight and
we'll see you back here again next week
on the law and crime trial network
you